it was the end of October in the
mountains in Austria I was down a field
trip with my architecture students from
Zurich and when we reached I have a
higher Valley I surprised them with the
news that there was no Hut a hotel
booked for the night it was not a
mistake it was totally on purpose the
challenge was to build our own shelter
with whatever we could find and we all
survived it was cold it was really tough
and it was a great learning experience
to discover that there a lot of
resources given by nature for free and
all that we need is our sensitivity to
serum and our creativity to use them I
found myself in a similar situation when
I was an architecture student about 13
years ago and went to Bangladesh to
remote village called little pool with
the aim to design and built the school
as Matisse's project I had lived in that
village before when I was 19 and a
volunteer deep chica a Bangladeshi india
for rural development and what I had
learned from them was that the most
sustainable strategy for for sustainable
development is to cherish and to use
your very own resources and potential
and not get depend on external factors
and this is what I tried to do with my
architecture as well in terms of
suitable building materials for my
school I didn't have to look far they
were right under my feet
mud earth dirt clay however you call it
and bamboo that was growing all around
electricity in remote Bangladesh is rare
but we didn't need it
we had human energy and people were
happy to have a work toast when is she -
but we had these guys water buffaloes we
had also tried it with cows
but interestingly there were two
intelligence they were always stepping
and the holes of the previous round they
wouldn't mix the mud this job this end
which are the ingredients in the walls
and except a small team of consultants
like my partner for realization I could
also work at my basket weaver cousin in
manual it was all built from craftsmen
from the village so and this is the meta
School of the six months of construction
thank you
no it's bearing Earthforce it really
ground the scone and a large family
structures that brings the lightness in
that's the classroom on the ground floor
pitched it are the caves there for
reading for snuggling for solo work for
meditation for playing and the classroom
on the top the children all signed with
the names in Bengali the doors and they
did not only sign they also hurting the
school and I'm sure you all have your
hands and mud or clay before it's
wonderful to touch I love it the
children loved it and can you imagine a
feeling of a small boy or a girl or an
illiterate day laborer is standing in
front of that school building and
knowing that you built this out of the
ordinary bamboo and it just the dirt
underneath your feet using nothing but
your hands that gives such an enormous
boost of trust and confidence in
yourself in the community and in the
material especially mud has a very poor
image when we think of not we think of
dirt it's ugly it's non durable and this
is the image I want to change in fact
it's the 11th rainy season for this
school now really harsh horizontal
monsoon rains and the walls are standing
strong
so how does that work first role a good
foundation that keeps the wall drive
from the ground and second role a good
roof
that protects from the top and third
rule erosion control mud walls need
speed breakers in order so that a
rainwater cannot run down the wall fast
and this speed breakers could be lines
of bamboo or stones or straw mixed into
the mud just like a hill needs trees or
rocks in order to prevent it to brand
erosion works just the same way and
people always ask me if I have to add
cement to the model and the answer is no
there is no stabilizer no coating on
these walls only in the foundation so
this is the close-up of the wall of the
ten years thing ten rainy seasons and as
much as I grew a bit older the wall got
some wrinkles as well the edges might
not be as sharp as before but it still
looks pretty good and if it needs
repairing it is really easy to do it
just take the broken part make it wet
and put it back on the wall and it will
look the same as before which it would
work on me - yeah and the great thing is
if an earth wall is not needed anymore
it can go back to the ground it came
from turn into a garden or get fully
recycled without any loss of quality
there is no other material that can do
this and this is why mud is so excellent
in terms of environmental performance
what about the economic sustainability
when we built the school I practically
lived on the construction sites and in
the evening and used to go with the
workers to the market and I could see
how they spent the money and they would
buy the vegetables from the neighbors
they would get a new haircut or a new
blouse from the tailor and because of
the because the main part of the
building budget was spent on
craftsmanship the school wasn't just a
building it became a real catalyst
for local development and that made me
happy if I had to sign the school and
cement and steel this money would have
been exported and lost for those mad
families the building budget at that
time was 35,000 euros probably double by
now and this is a lot of money for that
region and especially because this money
is working within a community and
rotating fast and not on the stock
market so when it comes to the
sustainability the economic
sustainability of my project my main
question is who gets the profit how many
of you and here's some experience in
living in a madhouse Chris Anderson
where's your hand.you
yeah it seems totally out of our focus
but approximately three billion people
all around the planet are living in
earth houses and it is a traditional
building material in Europe just as much
as in Africa strangely enough not is not
considered worthy of being studied at
universities so I brought the dirt to
Harvard precisely 60 tons of dirt right
in front of the main facade of the
Graduate School of Design students and
faculty rolled up the sleeves got the
hands dirty and transformed the front
into a warm place for people together
children will climb the structure
skaters would write the ramp students
having lunch breaks and it was
particularly fascinating to see how many
people were touching the wall and we
usually don't go around cities and
caressing all four sounds right
of course this was a small scale project
in terms of awareness building and in
terms of education was like an
acupuncture trigger point and in fact in
more and more countries earthen
structures load-bearing earthen
structures are not allowed to be built
anymore or so their traditional and has
lasted for hundreds of years and not
because the material is weak but because
there are no architects and engineers
who know how to deal with that material
so education on all levels for craftsmen
engineers and and architects is really
strong and aided equally important is
technological development like
prefabrication developed by my colleague
Martin Lau was an Austrian artist and an
expert in in earthen structures and he
has created technologies for rammed
earth elements for prefabrication of
rammed earth elements that include
insulation wall healings and Cooling's
and all sorts of electrical fittings
that can be layered to multi-storied
buildings and this is important in order
to scale up and in order to fast not the
processes like in the Ricola Center in
Switzerland and finally we need good
built projects that proof you can build
with an ancient material in a very
modern way it is not a matter how old
the material is it's a matter of our
creative ability to use it today this
for example is our three hostels that
they did in China and the in the village
house about six hours by bus from
Shanghai the outside shape is woven
bamboo and the inside core is stones and
ran to earth and it is a traditional
building material even large parts of
the Great Wall in China have been built
with rammed earth but it's getting
replaced by concrete and this trend it's
happening very fast within only a couple
of years China has consumed more cement
than the United States in the entire
20th century and this trend of replacing
natural building materials with
theories that require a lot of energy
that are energy intensive and that emit
co2 is really clearly contributing to
climate change and we have alternatives
such as mud stones timber bamboo earth
that are totally effective options for
all sorts of purposes this for example
is an office building that we did for
Omicron electronics in Austria not as
healthy for the planet but also for the
human bodies and the material is
low-tech but the performance is
high-tech the earth walls keep the
highly sophisticated tools in the
building safe the naturally regulating
moisture and this wall in my own home is
our humidifier
we love our six tons of dirt at home not
only because it's healthy and
sustainable it's our kind warmth is
touching deep within my personal dream
is to build a mud skyscraper right in
Manhattan yeah and this dream isn't so
crazy if you think of the mud city of
shabam in yemen that was built in the
16th century and has lasted now for five
hundred years what was possibly dead
long ago is possible today as well and
we can apply all our technique know how
to apply to this ancient material so
that it meets our needs and our dreams
all around us and just below our feet a
wonderful natural building materials
let's use them and I deeply believe our
homes our workspaces our cities would
become more healthy and sustainable and
more humane and beautiful thank you
[Applause]